[Musique]
terminées les vacances retour sur les
bancs de l'école pour les deux cent
vingt mille élèves réunionnais ce mardi
16 août en ce jour de rentrée scolaire
le président du département cyrille
melchior ainsi qu'une dizaine de
conseillers départementaux ont participé
à la cérémonie d'accueil des élèves de
6e pour leur premier jour au collège
l'oasis au port en présence de la
rectrice de l'académie chantal madness
bonnisseau l'occasion pour
l'établissement de faire découvrir les
récents aménagements financés par le
département ainsi que les nouveautés de
cette rentrée
les nouveautés de la fed seront très
larges sections international allemand
pour 22 élèves qui ont été sélectionnés
dont les écoles de nos secteurs mais qui
va s'ouvrir normalement
pour l'année prochaine sur normalement
le territoire de la réunion après on a
les deux heures de nouveautés de ps nous
on a aussi changé notre planning de
semaine c'est à dire qu'on a essayé de
faire dans les emplois du temps que les
élèves à partir de 15 heures de 15
heures à 17 heures ils puissent faire
autre chose que les cours obligatoires
donc il va y avoir du sport y avoir il
va y avoir le club sciences il va y
avoir le club éducation durable beaucoup
d'actions liées bas au quartier au
collège mais aussi lié à l'ouverture
dans le monde le développement durable
qu'est ce que c'est de nouvelles
sections sportives comme linguistique
des sanitaires flambant neuf pour les
professeurs un projet d'intégration des
sixièmes par le sport au collège l'oasis
on se veut innovant une prise
d'initiative que salue le président du
département c'est un collège qui est
dans l'innovation
quotidienne pense que vous savez que ici
nous sommes en zone d'éducation
prioritaire avec un environnement qui
n'est pas facile tous les jours au
quotidien les enfants doivent
accompagner les parents doivent être
sollicités et nous voulons d'une
réussite éducative la meilleure voie les
enfants aller le plus loin possible dans
leur réussite c'est pour cela que nous
sommes
si ce matin pour port donc au collège de
l'oasis le département bien sûr investi
dans des travaux d'amélioration de
rénovation de la sécurité de l'hygiène
et de l'accessibilité mais au-delà de ça
je vois aussi une équipe pédagogique
très entreprenante investi passionné par
ses missions dans le domaine du sport de
la pratique des langues dans le domaine
de l'éducation tout simplement et de la
citoyenneté alors bonne rentrée scolaire
à tous les marmailles de la réunion vol
rentrée scolaire aussi aux parents et
bonne rentrée scolaire aux professeurs
et aux agents techniques des collèges
qui sont les agents aussi du département
cyrille melchior a également tenu à
féliciter toute l'équipe enseignante et
le personnel du collège pour leur
implication dans la réussite et
l'épanouissement des élèves il ne leur
reste plus qu'à se mettre au travail
[Musique]